[Aplausos]
[Música]
Por qué una región con tantas
similitudes con Europa o Estados Unidos
es al mismo tiempo tan diferente cómo es
posible que la que fue durante
principios del siglo XX la región más
próspera de todo el mundo se haya
terminado convirtiendo en una pesadilla
de constantes crisis revoluciones y
asaltos golpistas Qué explica que esta
sea la realidad social en América Latina
y la pregunta de las preguntas por qué
demonios América Latina se ha quedado
tan atrás y sigue teniendo tantísimos
problemas en este vídeo queridos amigos
amigas os vamos a contar algunas de las
claves que explican porque un buen día
en esta región la prosperidad dio paso
al declive atentos
Pero antes dejadme haceros un apunte
sobre Rusia Putin la Guerra de Ucrania y
las sanciones internacionales en un
reciente vídeo aquí en visualpolitik os
contamos En qué estado se encuentra la
economía rusa sin embargo nos dejamos
varias cosas en el tintero que ahora
podéis ver en el último vídeo de si lo
hubiera sabido el canal de información
financiera de mutativos con el que
colaboramos si queréis saber cómo está
realmente la economía rusa No te pierdas
Este vídeo un vídeo que además viene con
sorpresa os dejo el enlace en la
descripción y dicho esto Ahora sí
arranquemos
[Música]
El despegue del Cóndor
una historia común y una identidad
cultural idiomática y social muy pero
que muy similar pensadlo bien pocas
regiones del mundo tienen tantos
elementos compartidos y tantas
similitudes como los países que integran
América Latina claro que para entender
su realidad hoy tenemos que remontarnos
hasta comienzos del siglo XIX cuando uno
tras otro prácticamente todos los
territorios latinoamericanos alcanzaron
su independencia Haití y el pistoletazo
de salida en 1804 y Poco después le
siguieron el resto de esta forma si para
comienzos del siglo XIX América Latina
seguía estando bajo dominio de España
Portugal y Francia para A mediados de
siglo ya podíamos encontrar un montón de
nuevas repúblicas nuevas repúblicas que
nacieron tras un proceso de
Independencia que también Tuvo muchos
rasgos comunes el movimiento fue
liderado por los propios descendientes
de los españoles se buscaba la
independencia de todo el territorio y no
solo de unos pocos países y fue
fundamentalmente un proceso impulsado
por las propias élites económicas y
políticas de la región es decir que por
mucho que hay algunos empeñen decir lo
contrario la independencia de América
Latina no tuvo nada que ver con una
revolución de clases ni nada por el
estilo tan solo tenemos que ver lo que
por ejemplo
pensaba del líder de la independencia
americana Simón Bolívar Bolívar es el
canalla más cobarde brutal y miserable
karl Marx en una carta Frederick engels
1858 sea como sea el caso es que las
nuevas repúblicas tenían tantísimos
recursos naturales que la mayoría de
ellas pronto empezaron a experimentar un
fuerte despegue económico rápidamente se
convirtieron en grandes potencias
agrícolas y mineras
las enormes plantaciones de café de
Brasil los extensos campos de trigo y
maíz de Uruguay y Argentina las minas de
oro en México o el cobre de chile fueron
un buen ejemplo de ello además por aquel
entonces el tamaño de estos nuevos
estados era muy pequeño mientras que la
facilidad para hacer negocios e inmigrar
era relativamente alta como podéis ver
esto hizo que entre 1900 y 1929 muchos
de estos países crecieran más que Europa
o Estados Unidos por entonces América
Latina era una de las regiones más
prósperas de todo el mundo y es que por
ejemplo el crecimiento de Venezuela
llegó a triplicar al de Estados Unidos
Claro que no todas las luces también
había muchas sombras y sobre todo una
destacaba por encima de todas las demás
y es que veréis en estos países donde el
sector agrícola tenía mucho pero que
Mucho peso la mayoría de las tierras
sobre todo los países relativamente más
pobres estaban en manos de grandes
terratenientes poco a poco este alimento
algunos movimientos Campesinos de
protesta como los que estaban detrás de
Emiliano Zapata en México o José María
de santogastiño en Brasil ya os hemos
dicho que la independencia sobre todo
por la oligarquía local familias
oligarquicas que habían hecho muchísimo
dinero Gracias precisamente a los
privilegios que la corona española les
otorgó durante siglos pero sea como sea
durante finales del siglo XIX y
comienzos del siglo XX Lo cierto es que
gran parte de América Latina disfrutó de
una enorme ola de prosperidad la máquina
funcionaba pleno rendimiento los barcos
repletos de inmigrantes no paraban de
llegar al continente desde la vieja
Europa y los productos latinoamericanos
estaban por todo el mundo Incluso en la
bolsa de Londres era habitual invertir
en productos financieros de países como
el argentino Brasil digamos que el sueño
americano también era cosa de América
Latina sin embargo en 1929 todo empezó a
cambiar de repente el motor se empezó a
gripar Por qué pues ahora mismo lo vamos
a ver
[Música]
[Aplausos]
el crack del 29
[Música]
[Aplausos]
los felices años 20 fueron años de una
enorme prosperidad fueron los años del
despegue definitivo de ciudades como
Buenos Aires México Df o Sao Paulo y
también de otras tan conocidas como
Sydney Toronto Chicago o Nueva York fue
una época que vio nacer grandes
rascacielos y en la que se popularizó el
uso del automóvil el teléfono o los
electrodomésticos en los países más
desarrollados a ritmos de charleston y
jacks el mundo parecía avanzar a toda
velocidad y desde luego América Latina
no era una excepción sin embargo todo
estalló en 1929 cuando el mundo comenzó
a experimentar la crisis económica más
traumática que se había conocido hasta
la fecha
[Música]
martes 29 de octubre el pánico recorre
las calles de Nueva York tras la caída
más precipitada de la historia de las
acciones
la caída que empezó el pasado jueves 24
de octubre amenaza con arrastrar a la
economía mundial la gente se apresura
intentar blindar sus riquezas ante unas
perspectivas poco halagüeñas que el
mundo está la expectativa de lo que
suceda en Nueva York
[Música]
Exacto queridos amigos amigas de
visualpolitik en 1929 el mundo se empezó
a hundir en una fuerte crisis económica
que terminó derivando el archiconocida a
gran depresión el comercio se contrajo
muchas empresas cerraron y millones y
millones de trabajadores terminaron en
el paro este fue un punto de inflexión
para muchos países y desgraciadamente
también para la mayoría de las jóvenes
repúblicas de América Latina digamos que
en ese momento se interpretó que el
modelo exportador que había reinado
durante décadas Aunque había creado
mucha riqueza también era extremadamente
vulnerable y sabéis que justo aquí es
cuando entra en escena un economista que
seguramente muchos no conoceréis pero
que podríamos decir que fue algo así
como la versión Latina de keyness Raúl
previtz
[Música]
a partir de la gran depresión las ideas
de este economista argentino se
expandieron y consolidaron por toda la
región más que un punto de inflexión fue
prácticamente un punto y aparte ahora
bien la pregunta que os estaréis
haciendo es pero Enrique y qué demonios
propuso exactamente este tipo Pues
básicamente un nuevo modelo de
desarrollo siento las bases Ni más ni
menos que del modelo conocido como
industrialización por sustitución de
importaciones la política económica
sobre la Capi votado desde entonces
Prácticamente todo América Latina
visualpoliticos hemos hablado de ella en
un montón de vídeos pero En qué
consistía exactamente pues fijaos la
estrategia de Raúl prebicera muy clara
América Latina tenía que
industrializarse y dejar atrás su
dependencia del campo y los recursos
naturales y no solo eso sobre todo tenía
que hacerlo mirando hacia adentro y no
hacia los mercados exteriores la idea
básicamente era producir en casa todo
aquello que se importaba para lograrlo
había que dar los siguientes pasos en
primer lugar aumentar los aranceles y
endurecer La regulación para encarecer
dificultar o incluso restringir las
compras en el extranjero la idea era
incentivar la producción nacional que
con este incremento del coste los
consumidores Pues optarán por la
producción nacional en lugar de
comprarse por ejemplo pues una clásica
chaqueta barbour británica si se
generaba esa demanda entonces las
empresas invertirían en incrementar su
producción y los países se
industrializarían por ejemplo el
nacimiento de empresas como la textil
iberoamericana o la textil Valeria en
Argentina Tuvieron mucho pero que mucho
que ver con este proceso
[Música]
Pero eso no es todo para acelerar el
proceso el estado tenía que intervenir
directamente para favorecer a la
emergente industria nacional era algo
que tenía que hacer por ejemplo dando
subvenciones y créditos en condiciones
muy preferentes a medida que estas
empresas crecieran crearían un montón de
puestos de trabajo y nuevos ingresos que
contribuirían a impulsar la demanda
además al no tener que importar tantos
productos saldrían muchos menos
capitales de la región esto permitiría
crearse un previs un enorme y próspero
mercado local que contribuiría no solo a
industrializar América Latina sino
también a mejorar más rápido los
estándares de vida digamos que en lugar
de crecer hacia fuera exportando lo que
perseguía era crecer hacia dentro había
por tanto que sustituir las
importaciones
desde entonces Este modelo se convirtió
en la política pública favorita de la
mayoría de los gobiernos de la región
por supuesto la Argentina de Juan
Domingo perón fue su alumno más
destacado y ojo porque en general este
nuevo modelo empezó pisando muy fuerte
sin embargo ya para finales de los 50 y
de los 60 se empezaron a ver los
primeros problemas la sustitución de
importaciones frenó la entrada de
inversión extranjera hizo que las
empresas locales pues al tener mercados
cautivos fueran mucho menos competitivas
y también hizo que el cambio tecnológico
fuera mucho más lento y además las
cuentas públicas los políticos
cada vez prometían más y más subsidios y
planes de estímulo para compensar todos
esos problemas y así pues poco a poco
fue creciendo otro de los grandes males
de la región atentos
la década perdida
a ver una pregunta qué hace un estado o
un gobierno cuando no tiene lo
suficiente para conseguir dinero rápido
pues muy fácil tiene que pedirlo
prestado por supuesto No toda la deuda
es igual no es lo mismo endeudarse para
pagar salarios públicos que por ejemplo
para construir una red de autopistas
porque las carreteras ya no dan abasto
El caso es que el modelo de sustitución
de importaciones no había creado
economías más pujantes pero sí estados
mucho más grandes y costes más elevados
Y con estas 70 además se produjo La
Tormenta perfecta por un lado la crisis
del petróleo redujo los ingresos
públicos de muchos de estos países Pero
por otro los planes de estímulo y
desarrollo económico hicieron que los
gobiernos necesitarán muchísimo más
dinero para sacar adelante sus planes el
resultado creo que en este caso una
imagen vale más que mil palabras los
gobiernos pidieron enormes cantidades de
dólares prestados a tipos variable
endeudarse moneda extranjera si es una
gran potencia comercial puede ser
llevadero pero si se ingresan pocos
dólares porque el comercio exterior es
reducido que es precisamente lo que
pasaba con el modelo de sustitución de
importaciones Entonces tienes un
problema y eso eso amigos es exactamente
lo que pasó
en 1980 la reserva Federal de Paul
Walker elevó con fuerza los tipos para
enfrentarse a la estanflación que
atravesaba el país para vencer la
inflación wilker empujó los tipos de
interés hasta el 19%, lo que disparó los
costes de la deuda en América Latina el
desastre estaba servido y la primera
economía en caer fue la mexicana que al
poco tiempo tuvo que pedir una moratoria
en el pago de su deuda esto hizo que la
confianza de los inversores en la región
terminara por desplomarse lo que supuso
aún una menor entrada de dólares fue así
como dio comienzo la conocida como
década perdida
[Música]
y ojo porque aquí no hubo diferencias
entre izquierdas o derechas desde el
México del izquierdista Pri hasta la
Colombia del conservador betancour
quarter la crisis fue devastadora para
todos y la pregunta es qué hicieron
Entonces todos estos gobiernos pues
desgraciadamente como ya no tenían
dinero a muchos no se les ocurrió otra
cosa que dar la máquina de imprimir
billetes ya sabéis para seguir
estimulando la economía esto hizo que de
repente las hiperinflaciones se
convirtieran en un patrón habitual en
toda la región
luego en los 90 los gobiernos intentaron
girar el timón pero los cimientos ya
estaban rotos una industria poco
competitiva y obsoleta gobiernos enormes
con muchos gastos y pocos ingresos bajas
tasas de inversión extranjera y
políticos acostumbrados a echarse en
brazos del Banco Central en otras
palabras los ingredientes perfectos que
nos ayudan a entender por qué esta
región no consigue salir de una puñetera
vez del Pozo con Raúl previtz América
Latina rechazó el comercio y se
distanció del modelo capitalista
imperante en Estados Unidos y Europa por
eso hoy nos puede sorprender que América
Latina Si al mismo tiempo tan similar y
tan distinta y a ver por supuesto
también podríamos hablar de los
movimientos populistas de los golpes de
estado o de las grandes deficiencias
institucionales pero sobre eso ya os
hemos hablado en varios vídeos tanto
aquí visualpolitik como en nuestro canal
hermano visual económico un momento aún
no lo conoces Pues no te olvides de
echarle un vistazo avísal economic y
también así lo hubiera sabido ya sabéis
que la familia crece y lo hace Gracias a
todos vosotros pero llegados hasta aquí
turno para ti crees que las ideas de
Raúl prebits fueron claves para la
crisis perpetua que vive América Latina
Qué otros factores tendrías en cuenta
déjanos tus impresiones en los
comentarios y ahora si este vídeo te ha
resultado interesante No olvides darle a
like y suscríbete a visualpolitik si es
que aún no lo has hecho un saludo y
hasta la próxima
[Música]